good afternoon cs109 and welcome to the
first day of fall quarter hey
I have not gotten to I was studying
abroad in Spring which means I haven't
gotten to start a class in person since
pre-pandemic and boy does it feel good I
am so happy to see you guys oh welcome
welcome to cs19 if you didn't expect me
to say cs109 this is your time to find
that cs103 class or that uh cs121 class
that you might be looking for but if
you're looking for a cs109 this is a
place coming in grab a seat I am Chris
and we're going to be learning about
probability for computer scientists
okay
shall we jump in
gather around I have such a story to
tell you guys today
and it's a story that computer
scientists know it's a story that
mathematicians should know but certainly
it's probably also a story that um all
people should know to some extent but
before I get into that I think I should
introduce myself hi I'm Chris I'm a
professor here in the computer science
department I'm also in the school of
education I'm in both places
um I teach and I research and I have a
good time I have a research lab it's AI
for social good we mostly do education
and some medical work as well uh I love
to teach I teach 109 I teach 106a I'll
teach cs398 I'll teach anything uh that
I can that I'm equipped to teach
um a small detail but um
I've been here for a while I actually
originally was born in Kenya when I was
12 I moved to Malaysia and then I came
here when I was 18. and I liked it so
much that I just decided to stay
um and because I've been here for so
long I was actually here as an
undergraduate and after undergraduate I
stayed for my PhD after my PhD they're
like you want to teach her I'm like yeah
that sounds cool so here I am
um when I was an undergraduate I
actually had the honor of being in the
world's very first cs109 class it was a
brand new class When I Was An
undergraduate I got to take the very
first one and look I was so young
anyways and I've been teaching for quite
a long time wow 2014. it's been a great
great run
so I love teaching and a lot of my
research actually involves teaching
because I love it so much one of the
things that I did during the pandemic is
we taught 20 000 students intro CS
around the world and we got the world's
the class with the most teachers in the
world we got trained 2 000 people up to
teach and they taught 20 000 students
and it was a good vibe it was just like
a little bit of community service and
then time pandemic
um
that also gives me a chance to tell you
a little about some of the research I do
we taught these 20 000 people how to
program but one of the things that I'm
intellectually curious about is how can
we understand humans who are learning uh
and so one of the things we tried to do
is said okay students are learning how
to code can we look at their code and
use some AI to analyze it and give
feedback and we had this nice little
result for the first time ever for
something as complicated as open-ended
code we're able to give feedback that
students preferred uh to TA feedback it
showed up in the New York Times amongst
other places
problems I'm also really interested in
how AI can help
teachers teach better and give
and how they could improve their craft
we tried all this stuff in code in place
and we've found ways that we could make
teachers even better at what they do and
that just scratches the surface of how
many cool problems there are in the
world
um you know I'm into things like
measuring how well people can see I'm
into things like can we figure out
fairness in artificial intelligence the
world is so full of things to be curious
about and whether the joys of being at
Stanford is I get to think about all
these wonderful diverse things
um outside of academics there's a whole
bunch of things I love too I love music
I love playing guitar Kenya and Malaysia
have some of the best food in the world
and I will argue with anybody that our
Cuisine is better I'm just joking I love
food I love cooking and I just love
science the last winter I went into the
forest and I found this wood covered
with this ice that was in the shape of
hairs and like our world is such a
beautiful beautiful place
um this is kind of a big deal in my life
I do a lot of research I do a lot of
teaching and then I've got this little
baby and so this summer was like
research half day teach half day and
then like make airplanes out of
cardboard uh which is like a total Joy
I'll tell you all about her
okay that's a little bit about me but
I'm just one of the people who's gonna
be teaching you cs109 cs1 is an
incredible 109 is an incredible course
and one of the things that makes it so
amazing we have such an awesome team of
uh Tas who are going to be helping us
through this journey and learning
probably are there any here today
hey we got a corner of Tas everybody
round of applause these guys are the
heart and soul of the class thank you
guys for what you do
[Applause]
okay I really want to get into content
but I do want to give you the most
important pieces of course mechanics but
the number one thing to take away from
today is we have a course web page it's
cs109.stanford.edu all the course
mechanics I mentioned you can go find on
that course website and you can go look
at the Nitty Gritty details for things
that you're curious about
though we should talk about some of the
things one of the things you might be
curious about am I in the right place
there's a lot of questions about
prerequisites and I just want to give
you an idea of what we actually are
going to be basing cs19 on top of we
really really assume that you know
cs106b coding we are going to talk about
things like recursion hash tables binary
trees
and also we're just going to assume a
certain maturity in coding some people
have managed to take cs106b alongside
cs109 uh that's fine but it's just a
really really important prerequisite a
less important prerequisite is cs103 uh
we just use some light bits of cs103 and
they mostly show up at the beginning of
class in fact one day I was curious
I there is all this card of data and I
was wondering how do people do in cs109
if they've never had cs103 before and
how do people do if they hadn't and I
found the surprising result that if you
didn't have cs103 you did slightly
better in cs9 now
as we'll talk about causality later in
this class but it's certainly not causal
it's probably just people who are
willing to skip cs103 might be coming
from a different population but long
story short we really don't rely too
much on the material from cs103 we do
rely heavily on material for math 51 or
CME 100. you know you're going to want
to know what a partial derivative is we
are going to teach you multivariate
integration if you hadn't seen it before
you'll see it in cs109 you know a lot of
the stuff I'd if you get there and
you're Rusty on it we're gonna help you
but this is just what we're assuming
coming in and certainly just some
notation we hope you're a little bit
familiar with uh if you just really
really want to take cs109 uh come and
you don't feel like you completely
mastered all the prerequises just come
talk to us we're happy to have that
conversation so yeah you're in the right
place
um
cs109 is a math course but we discovered
a while ago that math can really Bloom
when you can create things using math
not just solve problem sets but make
real things and to that end we are going
to use the math that you learn in this
class to make stuff and python is going
to be the language that you use to make
things in cs109 some of you probably
seen python before some of you haven't
if you haven't seen python that's
absolutely fine we're gonna have review
sessions to catch up on what you need
it's a beautiful language certainly
something you should know by the time
you graduate worth it come to the review
sessions as long as you've seen some
programming python is one of the kindest
and gentlest programming languages that
you could learn
okay
oh this is a very small thing you know
that there is a unit choice in Access
there really shouldn't be because
there's not really a choice it's a
deterministic decision mostly
start here are you an undergraduate
yes very simple five units if you
register for Access for less than five
units I get an email per student which
is a lot of emails let's say you're not
an undergraduate then ooh do you want to
take cs109 for Fiora units no guess what
five units
but if you did want to take cs1i for
fewer units I'm here to let you know
that you can if you're a graduate
student if you take it for three years
or four units the workload doesn't
change uh it's the same amount of work
for fewer units that's just life in grad
school uh welcome to adulting anyways
the really quick note on units so it's a
five unit class uh the way Stanford
units works is about three hours per
unit
so you can imagine
uh we're going to be spending about 15
hours per week on cs109 uh and a large
large majority of that will be you guys
doing your own work so 10 hours for
assignments a few hours for lecture and
a few hours for section
speaking of which what are the
components of this wonderful class well
as I mentioned one of the biggest
components is assignments you guys will
make things you'll derive things you'll
practice your art form of understanding
probability and that will be done uh in
your assignments and that's a good chunk
of cs109 and a good chunk of your grade
we do have exams we have a midterm and a
final exam you should show up they're
both going to be a good time we put a
lot of love to try and make it an
educational uplifting experience I'm not
really here to judge people I want you
guys to grow and improve as and hit your
potentials but anyways the final exam we
were told by the university do it then
and it's very very very very very very
very very very very very close
impossible to change only if you're like
a senior who's graduating this quarter
are there does the University make
exceptions the midterm we have a lot
more leeway on if you can't make this
time you just let us know close uh to
the date and we'll figure out something
for you so anyways we have these exams
if you're in a class that's at this
exact same time your exam is probably at
the exact at the same time and you
definitely want to solve that problem
now not at the end of the quarter okay
and then one of my favorite things about
cs109 it's fun to come to lecture you
guys should come to lecture we were
going to have a good time we're going to
do demos we're going to tell jokes we're
going to laugh hold hands sing Kumbaya
now we're not going to do that last part
but we are going to learn a lot of
probability
um but one of the best parts of the
classes then you get to meet in small
groups with one of our excellent World
expert Tas who will walk you through the
concepts so you can practice it before
you go off on your own into problem sets
uh it's a beautiful lecture than section
then do your work
I got this question a lot is this class
online uh it's recorded these wonderful
cameras we have an amazing amazing
amazing scpd team that's doing
professional recording of these classes
uh they'll be released about 24 hours
later so there's a few things to say
about that I love the recording you get
sick you can watch it later you didn't
catch something you can watch it later
realistically though some people are
gonna be like oh man my club really
needs me to do XYZ and I'll just catch
up on lecture later and we've all Fallen
to that trap so I want to talk a little
bit about you know the query we did
about people who had
um who had or hadn't done one of three
we can do the same thing based on how
people are watching uh lectures and we
know that coming to lectures people do
about a grade point hires again not
causal but come to lecture it's a good
time it'll help you stay on top
having said that I do think of you guys
as adults you're adults of course I
think if you as adults um and to that
extent you're in charge of making sure
you know this material you know find
your way it's just coming to lecture we
know is one of the best ways to do that
um and but I will leave it to your own
devices to how you're going to get to
the end of the score
you probably have questions in fact
somebody
from right now if you
have an electric you just raise your
hand and we'll get amongst it
there are other ways oh yeah
um the grading breakdown and the slide
is slightly different than the syllabus
which one is like oh definitely the one
in solos what did I get wrong here 40.
ah yeah I was gonna reveal that on
Wednesday no no no no no no that's great
that's great
um okay well okay the reveal is going to
come today
so I was thinking about this slide and I
was like well I want you guys to make
your own decisions I don't want to
penalize people I don't want to put in
um uh something that to force you to
come lecture but I do know that coming
to lecture is generally good for you
guys learning the material better so I
was like how could I incentivize this in
a nice and healthy way so what I was
going to do is I was going to put like a
really chill like you know code on the
the board and you can record if you came
to class and if you come to most of the
classes then I'll just slightly decrease
how much your final weighs into your
grade and I'll just give you full points
for that so just a small way to
encourage participation if you don't do
it can you still get 100 in the class
absolutely like if you never show up to
lecture but you show up to all your
sections that is important and then you
come to the final and you just rock it
you're like yeah I can do all this
probability you can get 100 in cs109 but
uh we know that the more reasonable path
to that coming to lecture participating
so we're going to incentivize that and
I'll give you all a little bit more
details about that on Wednesday but very
very very good question
okay
you might have other good questions
where are you going to ask your good
questions well you guys know q a forms
by now we use Ed instead of sending us
an email often it's better to post and a
lot of people will read that and get
back to you as soon as possible one of
the great places to go ask questions is
in person we do working office hours on
cs109 so you don't even have to have a
question you just go with your problems
and be like I'm gonna work on my problem
set and then when you have a question
you're already there what a time to be
alive so it is working office hours
they're going to start on Thursday and
we have a lot all of our Tas are doing
four office hours we've got so many off
stars for you guys because we want you
to get the help when you need it so
working off star is one of the great
places to get help and you can also
always email that email address and that
goes to me and all the Tas and we can
get you any help if you have anything
private that comes up that's going to
happen to some people you can email me
in the head ta will directly
and I also have one-on-one office hours
as opposed to group office hours so you
can come and ask me just questions there
okay questions on questions how meta
oh this is so cool
I first started writing lecture notes
for all my classes like okay what did I
talk about today and then over time it
became an entire reader so now I have an
entire reader for you I finally finished
it last year but now there's a cs19
reader it goes over a lot of the
concepts we talk about in class
um but just in a written form if you
like
there's this thing called an ace
companion course it's fantastic if you
want to take more units to cover this
material and get some more examples you
can take the ace class there's a
application form and you can learn more
about it by following the link it's both
in the slides and on the home page of
cs19 you guys want to see our homepage
it's really not that beautiful but I
designed it I'm not a designer and I
feel really good about some of the small
details it's not that important right
now what is important though uh is that
link is right over here so if you want
to apply to Ace there it is
uh and then I didn't go over all the
details but for all the details the way
you get all this information is on the
course website
uh under the course there's the syllabus
and you can read oh our wonderful Tas
and you read all about the details about
the course structure and we go into all
the nitty gritty
anxiety
any other questions
shall we let's do it I want to tell you
guys a story and I would like to tell
you the story of modern air and boy has
it become interesting in the last year
so
modern AI has this really interesting
story but if I had to give it a subtitle
it would be how we learn to combine
probability and programming together to
do very interesting things but I think I
should give some historical context you
know people thought AI would be a very
easy problem and a I'm going to speak
about broadly just computer is doing
human level intelligent things we
thought this would be simple in the
1950s computers start to do some awesome
things we got computers that could beat
any human in checkers
and then we got computers that could do
automatic proofs like you know imagine
the sort of proofs you would do in cs103
you had computers that could start to do
automatic theorem proving and we're like
yeah we're awesome AI gonna be super
simple and it led to ridiculousness
for example Herbert Simon uh one of the
leading AI researchers in 1952 said this
ridiculous thing on a grant that he won
that was worth the equivalent of like
half a billion dollars today he said
machines will be capable within 20 years
of doing any work a man could do which
is ridiculous for two years like or two
reasons like 1952 all the work a man can
do geez get with the times uh and then
the other things like imagine 1972
rookie machines able to do this no
they're basically like big calculators
by 1972. completely wrong you just
thought the world was pretty simple his
Grant was like first I will solve
language and then once I've solved
language then I will solve free thoughts
this is ridiculous anyways he didn't get
past language he started with
translation uh and this was he made this
thing a good translate from English to
Russian and and one of the funny
examples was
you could put in something like the
spirit is willing but the flesh as we
can get translated to Russian I didn't
understand Russian so I didn't include
it here but then you can take that
Russian and put it back to English and
see if it did a good job it's like the
vodka is good but the meat is rotten
which is funny but not at all the input
sentence
and you know what had happened
the world's just too complex what did he
try and do he tried to write all the
rules of English to Russian he's like
I'm just gonna spend this money we're
getting a lot of people will write all
these rules once you've written all the
rules then we'll have a translation
system but it turns out the world is so
complex and we don't understand it
because we have these beautiful
probability machines called brains and
these beautiful probability machines
have so much power and they're so good
about thinking about uncertainty
that we think uncertain problems are
easy but they are not as exemplified uh
by Herbert Simon and then we called we
got what we call the AI winter and for
decades no one would fund anybody not
just Herbert Simon uh anybody who said
their AI they'd be like
but obviously the AI winter is over and
something's going on you guys probably
know a lot about it a lot of its history
started here for example this is a
picture of
Stanley a car made at Stanford which was
one of the very first self-driving cars
so in 1997 we started to win at chess in
2005 we got cars that could drive
themselves in 2011 we had computers that
could play Jeopardy something had
started to change and obviously we know
that that was just the beginning you
know when I was in your seats crazy
thing someone told me there's this
problem called Speech the problem is you
get an audio recording of someone's
voice and then you have to write the
transcription of what they said that's
the problem of speech when I was in your
seats someone told me this problem will
not be solved in your academic lifetime
I was like whoa what a hard problem but
of course it has been solved we're very
very very good at that in fact my my
phone right now can do transcription for
my voice into written text
something really big can change between
when I was in your seats and now
you know board games yeah we're done
with board games and in fact the people
got so good at board games were like
let's do something real with this
technology and then started protein
folding if you don't know what protein
folding is is this very hard task of
taking the amino acid sequence and then
figuring out the 3D structure
and if you could do that you could
develop drugs faster you could
understand our bodies faster it is a
very interesting and wild world but it's
such a hard problem to figure out how
amino acid will become a 3D structure
that we thought you know we won't be
able to do it but as of a couple years
ago not only are we good but we have
we've come up with a 3D structure for
every single known amino acid sequence
in some popular database which I can't
remember the name of
but you know AI is not just those flashy
things AI is also in our day-to-day
lives like when you say I want to go
from San Francisco to Mexico City and
you get this route and it's a little bit
of artificial intelligence that's
helping you figure out your path and you
know translations got a whole bunch
better than when Herbert Simon was
working on it if you're in Silicon
Valley or self-driving cars well
actually I have no idea how they're
doing they haven't hit me yet okay
and you know it's always been an
exciting time
but then this year everything seemed to
change once again this is just kind of
like a timeline since May
um and all of a sudden we've started to
get these huge results in artificial
intelligence in a world that people are
starting to call large language models
but basically they're these like half
billion dollar AI systems that people
have started to make public for other
people to use
I was playing with my 18 or not 20 month
old daughter uh a little while ago and
we opened up one of these AI systems
these AI systems can do different things
the one we use would take text and when
you wrote text it would infer the
distribution of that text it would then
go figure out what is the probability
distribution of all the images that
relate to this text conditioned on what
was written and then it can sample you a
few different images from that
probability distribution that's insanity
but for my 20 month old daughter it's
just like she writes three birdies happy
and she gets this picture or she writes
you know robot Messiah and she gets this
picture out in fact have you guys seen
this is anyone who's not seen this live
do you guys want to see it I need a
prompt though
uh let's say a rabbit and a giraffe
in an airplane so this is a one AI model
called dully it's going to take that
sentence it's going to try and sample
from the probability distribution of
images related to that sentence and this
is something that came out about six
months ago
we can also oh there you go and he
constructed these images oh that's so
cute look it's got like a little heart
there ah okay
and these aren't pictures found on the
internet you know it just constructed
those pictures from scratches thinking
about probably distributions over images
what a time so much is happening so fast
and every problem that's gets solved
seems to open up a whole bunch of open
new problems
oh so hopefully at this point I've
convinced you that stuff's happening but
you might be curious like Chris what's
really going on under the hood well I'm
going to start telling you that story
now but really cs109 is a class where
we're going to understand this story
more deeply
oh a little bit of suspense
this is so fun to have been starting a
class in person for so long okay let's
focus on one problem uh this is the fun
problem called Chihuahua or muffin
you may think it's easy but you know
originally when I was working on AI this
would have seemed like an impossible
task uh first of all let's just take a
moment to appreciate how smart we are as
humans and feel better than the machines
for a moment
okay just yell it out loud
you guys are good
a little tricky because the blueberries
arranged like eyes and but you're right
it is in fact a muffin okay how about
now
that was very impressive okay humans are
getting smarter too
you know why is this problem so hard
it's like when you're seeing this it's
hard to separate the fact that you have
billions of neurons which are activating
and they're lighting up in response to
your retina you're having this
experience of Chihuahua but that's a
huge amount of processing that leads to
the experience of Chihuahua for both
your eyes and for computers it starts
like this you either have Retina
responses or in the case of a computer
vision you have pixel values and you
have to understand what's in an image
just from Pixel values you just look at
those raw numbers it is very hard to
tell
we have this thing called a visual
cortex and about 30 of your brain is
dedicated to seeing so when you perceive
the world you have a huge huge mechanism
that is behind that what seems easy to
you is actually using one of the world's
most powerful computers
okay I'm going to show you this example
using numbers this is going to be my
hard example what digit is this
oh no it's supposed to be a zero I
really did choose a hard one and how
about this one okay it's a little bit
easier for I mean instead of Chihuahuas
and muffins I'm gonna do uses yours and
one's a little bit more straightforward
you know you can imagine one of the AI
tasks that you can do is to build an
algorithm which can detect Chihuahua or
muffin Oregon techs are one or a zero
that's hand drawn it's a classification
algorithm it looks at a picture and it
classifies it as either group a or group
b or in this group group one or group
zero so we're going to make this AI
algorithm we wanted to look at a picture
and say something like this is a picture
of one and look at this picture and say
something like this is a picture of a
zero that's our goal this particular AI
algorithm task is called classification
um it's not always perfect AI doesn't
have to always be perfect but we want it
to be fair and we also want it to be
about as accurate as possible
Okay so
how could we do this we're not going to
go down the Herbert Simon approach we're
not going to try and write all the rules
of what makes for a one or a zero we're
not going to try to write all the rules
of makes for a Chihuahua or muffin it
just turns out this approach doesn't
work the world is too complicated
so instead let's use some insights I'm
going to tell you two great ideas one is
artificial intelligence artificial
neurons as simple probability machines
and then this idea of learning by
examples
shall we let's do it okay our brains are
smart we have neurons so can we make a
cartoon model of that here is a cartoon
model of how your brain works you've got
billions of these things called neurons
neurons get inputs those inputs lead to
a buildup charge in the nucleus of the
neuron and if that charge gets big
enough the neuron starts firing
those inputs get weighted differently so
your brain can decide to pay attention
to some neurons more than other neurons
uh and and that's kind of your cartoon
model
we can build a cartoon version of this
and in fact we have done that we build
these cartoon models they have inputs
each input can be weighted and then
we're going to start firing or not
firing in fact when we build these
cartoon models we built probability
Theory into it from first principle so
we interpret the output as a probability
of firing or a probability of not firing
this was a great idea and this idea
changed the world not because you can
get intelligence from one neuron but
because you can start to put them
together
just to walk you through this metaphor
really quickly these cartoon neurons
that have inputs those are like the
inputs to a human neuron and those could
have different values
every value we're going to wait and then
we're going to sum up all the weighted
values and once we sum up all the
weighted values you know you can imagine
it's like this little nice little
mathematical Foundation where again then
put it through a squashing function that
gives an output that looks a little bit
like a probability I said a whole bunch
but at the end of the day this is a very
digestible model if you spend you know
10 minutes looking at you it starts to
feel a little bit comfortable you know a
little cartoon model inputs get weighted
some squashed think of the output as a
probability
that was our cartoon model of a neuron
but the beautiful thing about these is
you don't get a lot of intelligence from
one neuron you get a lot of intelligence
from putting a bunch of neurons together
and so people started taking these
little probability Lego blocks and
putting them on top of each other and
you could put a bunch of them together
in a computer and you can end up with a
bigger probability machine
sometimes we'll represent it with layers
like you have your input layers and then
layers of hidden neurons and then a
final layer and people would build these
probability machines they would make the
inputs equal to the pixel values and
then they would try and get neurons in
the middle to Fire and not fire and
eventually they would have a very final
neuron and that very final neuron would
end up with a probability output and we
would interpret that as a probability of
a classification
it was a good idea
and you know people would make these
bigger and bigger and bigger I won't go
I won't go into oh let's take a look do
you guys want to see one
oh yeah blocked
okay that's okay the picture captures it
uh and yeah so people would build these
huge neurons neural networks this is a
visualization one where you have
hand-drawn digit here and then you just
have these layers of those tiny little
blago blocks I describe they're tiny
little probably uh units stacked on top
of each other and they would each be
Computing some probability on top of
previously computed probabilities at the
end we would have a bunch of neurons
which would represent either this is a
zero or one two three four five six
seven eight or nine it was a simple
model but you know I've told you about
this model I've given you no reason to
believe that it's intelligent
you can make this model you guys could
code it up but where does the
intelligence come from
the intelligence is embodied in this
model where does it live
and the answer is it's in these weights
you know how you set these weights can
make you can construct this whole Lego
structure of these probability units and
the intelligence will come from having
well set weights if you have well set
weights you can have good probabilities
which have meaning
well if you could get perfect weights
you'd have intelligence
do we hire grad students to go and just
like fiddle around with those weights no
it'd be great if we could get those
weights in a more automatic way which
leads to our second great idea learning
by example
humans have beautiful brains but we also
have this experience of learning by
trying things you know we're not always
just given uh
rules on how the world work we go
experience the world and we get smarter
through experiencing and so there was
this great idea in probability in the
90s which was let's learn from example
so imagine a single neuron you have
these weights if they were the perfect
weights it could be a smart neuron if
they're random weights it's not a smart
neuron and we want to get those weights
to be really smart you know what people
did they would take examples
you know take this zero turn on your
neuron have it fire
and then if it was wrong like this case
it predicts it's a one when really it's
a zero what we would do is we would say
hey algorithm could you adjust your
weights so that you would be a little
less wrong
and the algorithm is like you know what
I can you know why because I'm based on
probability Theory because I'm based on
probability Theory I can formulate that
request mathematically and since I can
formulate that that request
mathematically as a computer I can do
that I can take this input this example
and I can change my weight so that I
could have been smarter
uh and if you do this a little bit over
and over again and just get a little
smarter every time you see an example
eventually these models become
intelligent over time
and it really starts with this you know
the neural network at its end makes a
probability claim it says the
probability that this is a zero is
something like 0.9 and you say
um but you know it's actually a one and
so we're going to give you some loss uh
and and then it says okay how could I
have to update myself and it says well
that was my probability that's my claim
I can understand these from my
probability basis and then I can ask how
could I change so that I could have been
better how could what is my change in
weights that would improve or minimize
my loss as much as possible
and like there you go you can just write
it as a formula and some of you guys are
looking like what you mean you can just
write out the formula that looks
incredibly scary here's the beautiful
thing about cs109 this looks scary right
now this is something every single
person in this class is going to master
and feel very comfortable with and you
will understand that mathematics that is
the basis of this huge revolution in Ai
and it's not just the basis of this
revolution AI is math that will continue
to change the world it is math
absolutely worth knowing you will walk
out of the class knowing what all of
this means
of course we're not there yet you're not
supposed to look at that and be like
yeah obviously it's the derivative of
loss with respect to each of the weights
um that's where we're going to get to
in cs109 we're going to get there and
not only are you going to be able to
derive these we're going to derive all
this work and then we're going to use it
to start to solve some problems uh we're
going to solve some interesting problems
like detecting heart disease figuring
out what movies people like
um and doing some DNA analysis
and you know I've told this story
through Chihuahuas and muffins but one
of the interesting things happening AI
right now is we have these tools
when you learn how to use these and you
learn how to use them appropriately
then the next question is what problems
do you want to solve
and we all have different answers for
that but I would love to see these tools
in your hands because I bet you guys
would think of the coolest most useful
things to do with uh with this like for
example instead of detecting Chihuahuas
versus muffins one of the things that
somebody here at Stanford figured out
was can we take a photo of somebody's
skin and detect is this cancer or not
cancer and there's a lot of interesting
things to say about this but one of the
things I'd like to point out is this is
somebody who was just a few years older
than most of you guys in this class and
this was only a few years ago somebody
at Stanford took some of these models
that we're going to learn about and did
something really worthwhile
okay so what's the story so far hey guys
going through a huge change and so far
in its history not once but twice AI was
Revolution advised people who understood
their probability Theory really well
end of story
accept it no sorry too much suspense
except it obviously isn't the end of the
story it just keeps changing uh and
there's not the end of the story for a
bunch of reasons we're going to learn
core probability theory in cs109 it'll
be driven by application it'll be driven
by our desire to understand this world
but you're going to learn this
fundamental theory that explains a lot
of natural phenomena and it's gonna be
much more useful than just learning
there is abundance of important problems
and I'm going to just show you one open
problem that computers are really not
that good at
so this is a problem of One-Shot
learning I'm going to show you an
example of a single symbol and can you
recognize which of these is an example
another instance of that symbol so
that's your single training and I want
you to figure out which of these is
another example is this it
is this it is this it is this it
ah fantastic you guys are this part you
just
you just that it's amazing humans are
brilliant in that way but typical
machine learning often needs to see
millions and millions of examples and
this is an example of you know we really
have a lot left to do in the world of AI
if you learn your probability it's not
just good for machine learning if you're
really into algorithms you just want to
go into 161 you want to understand how
all these different algorithms that have
allowed us to use computers in such
effective ways work you want to
understand your probability so many
modern algorithms use probabilistic
analysis for telling the story of how
they work so well and they use
probabilistic analysis for great ideas
and how to make cool ideas much faster
we've all lived outside of the
university and had experiences where
probability could help us make good
decisions there is this other part to
cs19 I'll teach you fundamental
probability and there's going to be
times in your life when you will really
appreciate that when somebody gives you
a probabilistic claim that you can
understand what that means if somebody
gives you a probabilistic claim and you
get more information you can understand
how to incorporate that more information
to improve your probabilistic
understanding and it just makes us
better understand the world around us
and if you understand the world around
us you can start to build things for
that world
a couple other cool examples you know
some things aren't traditional AI with
deep learning but maybe you want to be
using some interesting conditional
probability
like recommender systems are some
examples of that
uh what a time my god with so much
moving we need people to be building
useful and important things with
technology but we also need people who
understand it very well to figure out
how it could be used wrong and to be
able to figure out when other people are
doing things that we don't like uh
ethics has become more and more
important and it's not just ethics it's
the codification of Ethics into things
like law there's huge fields and careers
to be made if you care about
intersections Beyond just you know
making the next cool Dolly image
generator but
are cool too maybe you want to
understand how it made this picture of
this giraffe and this uh bunny on this
airplane
sorry this is the image of image
generation from like two years ago and
this is where it is now it's changed a
lot I had to update my slides
okay but you know there's a few stories
I hope you guys are just excited to
learn this for the the pure joy of
understanding how the world works the
pure joy of learning tools that will
allow you to build things that other
people can't build but you know there is
this practical side too it turns out
this is the concept that is one at most
demand in industry and also in Academia
they did this survey for PhD students
coming in they said what do you wish you
knew better upon graduation and and the
most common answer was a better
understanding of probability it's a cool
thing to learn it's going to enrich us
as people we'll walk out just being a
little bit more enlightened into the
complexity of this world and we'll be
able to do some cool stuff
speaking of cool stuff
here's just one story to tell you about
how we try and incorporate the real
world into cs109
ah spring 2017 what innocent days
anyways spring 17
people in cs109 came in for their final
and there was this problem and the
problem says hey you've been learning a
lot of probability Theory let's use it
to make a really smart eye exam have you
guys ever been to the eye doctor and
they have you like close one eye and
they're like that's an e that's an a
they're like that's not an a that's a b
what are you talking about you know that
one
it's not the best exam and so on the on
their midterm in Spring 2017 their job
was used probability to come up with a
better exam I just thought this was a
neat problem because I was like trying
to write my exam while at the eye
doctors I'm like this is boring the
story I'm like oh I got a midterm
problem this is awesome
um and you know when you think about
this probabilistically you can take
information like what questions people
have gotten right or wrong and you can
develop a belief distribution over how
well somebody can see and that's
interesting because if you have a belief
distribution over how well somebody can
see you can make an intelligent decision
under uncertainty for what to show next
as a letter and then based on this you
can make an algorithm which could
dynamically give people different
prompts for what they could answer and
this is a plot of how long an exam is
and this is a plot of how crappy it is
you want to be low because crappy is bad
that is the exam that you get at the
doctors the blue one can be short or
long but generally not very good the
black one is the research exam so if you
want to end up in a paper you have to
study people's eyes using that black dot
but using the cs109 algorithm we get way
more accurate for much much shorter
exams which is exciting and we could
tell that story in lots of these
beautiful probability plots which we'll
get into later in the class
it started in cs109 it was just a
midterm problem and then a guy like
published in science and the landsat and
you know you have the Stanford Acuity
test which started in our class
and it just tells the story of all these
open problems you might feel like
probability assault it is not solved
there's so many intersections think
about something you love think about
something you love that maybe not
everybody loves there's a good chance
there is a meaty interesting problem in
the intersection of probability computer
science and that thing that you love
we'll try and explore different ones
like for example uh on last year's final
we did things like you know taking
chess.com puzzles and figuring out how
people good people are
um P hacking supply chain decision
making uh algorithmic art like how can
you use probably to just make some
beautiful images and on exams people
made images like this ah so beautiful
you're like exams are stressful man and
people are not looking for Beauty on
exams but that's a philosophy we can get
into later
okay
it's a foundation for your future but
not always the most intuitive thing I'm
going to tell you honestly when I
learned probably in high school I'm like
well thank God I'm never going to need
this in my life because I want to study
the other fields of math and I was
completely wrong
um I just found it rather unintuitive I
didn't understand how much it was going
to change the world when I was in high
school to give you an example of what I
mean when I say probably isn't always
intuitive let me give you this canonical
example
imagine a patient has a positive zika
test and this is something that we can
probably relate to from the two years of
thinking about probability on testing
so if somebody has a positive zika test
how could you reason about the
probability that they actually have zika
I'm separating the idea that they had a
test that that says they have zika from
the underlying truth that they actually
have the disease
we need some more information to answer
this question so I'll give you some more
information very few people actually
have zikra
and then this test is not perfect
so if people have zika 90 percent of the
time they'll say you have zika and
people don't have zika seven percent of
the time you'll say you have zika you
know how could it say you have zika if
you don't have it well we know tests
aren't perfect so if you don't have zika
there's a chance that it'll still say
you have it
so now you have enough information to
answer this question what's the
probability that you have zika
you just got a positive test but the
right answer turns out to be only nine
percent
do you guys find that unintuitive you
just had a test that says you have zika
it's a pretty good test like those
aren't bad numbers yet you're probably
having zika is still very very low
and what's going on here well you know
one of certainly influencing factors is
the fact that not many people actually
have zika but if you want to understand
this deeply you'd need to know your
probability Theory and certainly the
probability Theory would help you get to
this answer
but the one thing people don't often
appreciate is you will then get more
information the next day you'll feel a
little bit better you'll feel a little
bit worse and probably Philly Theory
gives you clean way to update beliefs
over evidence so the more information
you gather you can keep updating your
chance of anything you care about
inferring in this case whether or not
you have a disease do you guys find that
on YouTube whoa small number
so here we end up with this story
probably
important and something that needs study
it's a
something hard to learn on your own if
you're not in the classroom
so okay here's my view of probability in
cs109
I'm going to teach you some beautiful
Theory and the Beautiful theory that you
need to do the math that most people are
not able to do so that you can build and
create things that will bring some
Wonder into some people's lives
gets you through this wonderful Journey
it's not just about AI it's also about
this uncertainty Theory and
understanding probabilistic models that
we're going to get to but in order to
get there we need to build a foundation
first you need to understand your Basics
inside and out because when you get to
this stuff it will get a little more
complicated and so our job is to build
this solid foundation upon which you can
then improve and 109 is just the start
of your journey you're going to take
further classes and see us and they're
going to build upon this even further so
let's really make the sound Foundation
Rock Solid how's that sound your future
cells are going to love you they're like
thank you for making my foundation so
rock solid no problem pass me as into
that sort of stuff okay
so I'm excited you can tell I'm excited
um and but at this point it'd be really
fun to dive in so I'd like to get us to
this point of understanding the Deep
philosophy behind things like artificial
intelligence and algorithms like making
decisions under uncertainty but we got
to build that Foundation you want to
start right now we don't have to wait we
can just do it now
let's do it okay I do this thing these
classes are long and they're long
because it turns out probability
Foundation has to be pretty hefty
but I want you guys to be able to take
things in I've talked about a lot of
things what I'm going to do now is going
to give you two minute pedagogy Applause
I want you to meet the person next to
you if you already know them great get
to know them a little bit better if you
don't know them get to know them a
little bit better because we're going to
be on this journey together two minute
pedagogical pause just talk to somebody
then we'll talk about some material
let's bring on back
okay
let's do this let's build ourselves a
foundation some people are like
foundations are just not that exciting
but houses are exciting you know
foundations thing a house goes on and
you're like I just want to make a house
I want to make a tower I want to make a
beautiful castle I want to make
something exciting have you ever tried
to make a house without a foundation not
so exciting you got to build it's like
it just feels like hole in a ground
filled with concrete but like no this is
where it all starts this is the Bedrock
and the foundation of probability theory
is hilariously encounting and you might
think like Chris I'm pretty good at
counting I've been counting since I was
two well today you're going to learn how
to really count
um probability gets its Genesis from
Counting Theory and it turns out when
people are trying to understand how
probability related to the world of
mathematics is through counting that we
were able to deeply understand it if you
could understand counting it will
provide that foundation for you but it
also turns out it's a nice intuitive
Direction into probability Theory it's a
it's an easier space to reason about and
it will give you a lot of the same
insights that show up in probability
Theory counting is also useful as a
computer scientist because a lot of
times you're trying to decide am I
writing an algorithm that will
eventually stop and a lot of times
that's like how many iterations do I
have to do and I actually have to count
it and so counting really is that
process of counting how many elements
there are
in probably Theory we have a slight
formalization but it's no more
complicated than you imagine we think of
an experiment so you're going to do
something and that doing something can
have outcomes and we're going to think
about how many unique outcomes there are
um
so let me give you an example I've got a
dice here and I can roll that Dice and
you can imagine rolling the rice as the
experiment and the outcome is just which
side of the dice we see so if we think
about it how many outcomes can you get
from rolling a single dice well there's
six outcomes you get one two three four
five six there's these nice discrete
outcomes to Rolling a single dice
what about how many ways could you roll
a dice that where you have only evens
well you can imagine my experiment is
rolling the dice there's still six
outcomes but only three of those
outcomes satisfy the the idea that you
have an even outcome on your dice this
is just a little bit of terminology so
counting we're going to think about
experiments and we're going to think
about counting events and what we're
going to think about counting the
outcomes that satisfy the idea behind
those events so rolling single dice how
many ways to get evens there's just
three ways two four or six
bump this up a notch you know rolling
two dice isn't that bumped up but we can
really take this uh to very interesting
places and if you roll two dice you can
imagine thinking about all the different
outcomes of rolling two dice you know
you can have a one and a one and you
have a one and a two and one and a three
and you can sit there and go through
every possible combination write them
all down and eventually get that there's
36 different outcomes
and we can write them all out here you
know here's the one in the one here's
the one and the two the two and the one
and so on so forth
so here's a little bit of a
first rule to start thinking about this
you could have counted 36 for the number
of outcomes in dice but it turns out
we're going to learn our very first rule
to make counting a little bit easier
this is one of the two core ideas to
Counting turns out if you know two ideas
in counting how to count with steps and
how account with or you could derive all
the higher level counting that you could
ever want so if you can really Master
these two everything falls from them
the first idea is if I wanted to count
that there's 36 outcomes to these two
dice
here is one of the rules you can do you
can break down this experiment into
steps and anytime you can break down
experiment into steps you can use one of
your major Pathways to Counting called
the step rule of counting okay I told
you there's a little bit of Reliance on
106 or sorry 103 and this is kind of
what it looks like we assume that you've
heard of sets before
and we've assumed that you've seen
notation like this those vertical lines
meaning the size of a set but if you've
not seen that before study this notation
and that's kind of the prerequisite that
you would need to know you need to feel
comfortable with some of this set
notation
so we're going to say the outcomes to an
experiment if you break it down to steps
could be thought of using the step rule
of counting so when I say breaking down
to steps let's say the outcome of an
experiment comes from two steps steps a
and step B and step a will have its own
set of outcomes and step B will have its
own set of outcomes and let's say
there's some number of outcomes in Step
a and some number of outcomes in Step B
the step rule of counting says if it is
such that the first step doesn't affect
how many options there are in the Second
Step so your first choice isn't changing
how many choices you have in the step
second choice you can just figure out
the number of outcomes using
multiplication so if you have it
so if you have a two-step process
where you have step one
has a outcomes and step two
has B outcomes if after step one there's
always the same number of outcomes in
step two the total number of steps in
your two-step process is just going to
be the size of number of outcomes in a
times the size of number outcomes in B
you know you could have named the number
of outcomes in am and you could have
named the number of outcomes in b n and
then would just be M times n this is a
really really fancy way of saying if you
can figure out an experiment and break
it down into steps you can just use
multiplication to do your Counting
I love this example there's so many
beautiful things to be said about
counting why it's interesting just from
the single example not too long ago
there was this art project
they took 12 pixels
and they were going to try and generate
every possible image that you could with
12 pixels
so you can imagine first they start with
these pixels then you could slightly
tweak this pixel then you can slightly
tweak this pixel and they're going to
try and generate every single possible
image
so my question for you is how many
Unique Images can you get from 12 pixels
and this will give us an idea if you're
a computer scientist you might want to
care how much work there is in this task
but also it's going to be Pro a good
practice in this first most important
rule of counting the step rule of
counting so see if you can use a step
roll of counting to answer the question
how many Unique Images are there for 12
pixels I'm going to give you an
important fact and I can derive it for
you later
there's this idea of how many colors can
each pixel be
and it's about 17 million
there's 256 options for red 256 options
for blue and 256 options for green in
how computers represent colors and so if
you multiply 256 times 256 times 256
because you think of the process of
choosing color as choose your red then
choose your green then choose your blue
put that together you have a color three
steps no step changes how many options
you have the other ones 256 times 250
times 256 gets you 17 million there's
about 17 Millions at a computer 17
million different colors that a computer
can represent for every pixel so if you
have 12 how many different Unique Images
were they going to generate in this
piece of artwork talk to the person next
to you get to know them them try and
solve this interesting math problem try
and talk about it in the terms of the
step rule of counting and think about
what your steps are I'll give you a
moment to think about it
oh this is great that is so wonderful
just to hear people thinking you we're
all going on this journey together we're
going to spend you know 10 weeks that
we're going to be synchronously trying
to learn the beauty of probability
together as a team what a beautiful
thing and I just this cacophony of
people thinking about a problem just
really exemplifies that for me thank you
thank you for that okay let's do it
together though
um how did people think about how many
Unique Images are how could you break
this into steps did somebody come up
with a series of steps that they want to
share with people
right and each of the pixels can be one
of 2.6 cubed million just like two six
cubed colors and so if each of them were
independent and they're not influencing
the number of outcomes the other pixels
have
that what you could do is just multiply
the number of outcomes of each pixel
where's your steps this is exactly right
but I just want to use the language of
steps what are the steps how many steps
are there and what's your first step
right the first step is determining the
color of the first pixel so we got pixel
one step one choose that color
does that change how many colors you're
allowed to choose for Pixel 2 no no it
doesn't infect at all so step two what's
step two you determine the volume of
that pixel so and how many steps we have
well yeah 12 steps and no choice for
anyone so that changes how many choices
you have for the other one that's why we
can just multiply and how many choices
you have for step one you send me 256
cubed that's 17 million so 17 million
times how many steps for two two seventy
million you're like that's a lot two
pixels is all we need uh but no no there
are more 70 million times 70 million
times 70 million you guys want to see
what that looks like
I put up a lot of these questions
you guys I love programming so I made
this thing called the pset app so you
guys can do stuff in this like super
cool app and I put all the the problems
from today's lecture there too so you
can try them out get your answer and put
them in here this is how many Unique
Images can you guys see that number
oh
okay well that is the number which is
how many Unique Images there are from 12
freaking pixels
that's 20 you know uh sorry 17 million
times by itself 12 different times this
is what that looks like uh and you know
12 to the power
or sorry 17 million to the power of 12.
and why is it 17 million to the power of
12 and not the other way around is
because
you have 17 million
times 70 million times 17 million times
itself 12 different times that's how you
can get 17 million to the power of 12 as
being the number of Unique Images 5.8
times 10 to the power of 77 doesn't look
that large
you're like that looks pretty large uh
and it really looks large when you look
at it in terms of just this raw number
that is what that that's how many Unique
Images you can get from the 12 pixels
wow I did want to just review you know I
said that there's
17 million it's because every single
pixel has a red Channel
which has 256 and blue which is 256 and
green which is 256 options
so you can imagine every single Pixel
you think of it as three steps choose
your red choose your blue choose a green
do you know why 256
step rule of counting again there's
actually eight bits to represent
the red channel so there's eight
different places where you can choose a
zero or a one
so if you have eight bits and this could
be zero one there's two choices here two
choices for zero one here two choices
two choices two which is two choices two
choices
if you have eight binary values
how many unique numbers can you make
to the power of eight equals 256. step
rule of counting is just all over uh
okay
so if 17 million to the power of 12 is
how many images you get from picture C
how many Unique Images are there from
picture B you just yell it out loud
17 million to the power 300 do you know
how big that is
okay to give you a sense
that
people have estimated how many atoms
there are in the known universe like if
you went and counted every items like
you need better things to do but if you
went and counted every item we think you
would get to about 10 to the power of
80.
do you remember how big this number was
it was 10 to the power of 77. there is
almost as many Unique Images in these
bloody 12 pixels as there are atoms in
the known universe
17 million to the power of 300 isn't
more than the number of atoms in the
universe it's so much more and if you
get to something like 12 million pixels
which is like small compared to what
your your phone can do
it makes the number of atoms in the
universe look like an infinitesimally
small number in fact you would have to
have a whole universe inside of every
single atom to even get remotely close
to how many Unique Images there are
this matters this explains why some
things are hard for computers why
computations can be hard to compute
being able to count and being able to
kind of avoid the step rule of counting
in some of your algorithms is key to
being computer scientist but there's
also some deep philosophy here can I
just aside for a moment
have you guys ever wondered how are we
going to as a species keep trying to
grow in a world with finite resources
like we have a whole society based off
of infinite growth but we have a world
that only has finite things
that seems like a problem right
and it is true there are finite atoms
and there's finite things in this world
but once you get into the world of
counting in combinatorics there are so
many infinities of combinations of
things we live in a world where there
might be finite things but there's
Infinite combination of those things
it's not an infinite but just you know
the step rule of counting leads to so
many unique combinations so fast that
our world of combinations is incredibly
large and I just find this like some
nice little philosophy uh for your first
day of class anyways long story short
the answer is 17 million to the power of
n where n is the number of unique pixels
um and what we think about the number of
Unique Images we're now talking about
way more than the number of atoms in the
known universe
how cool is that
okay so uh here's your numbers is 72
million to the power of n
um oh well slightly off but uh
incredibly incredibly large numbers
so I told you that the step rule of
counting was one of two fundamental
rules and if you can Master these two
fundamental rules you could derive
basically all of the mathematical field
of combin torques which is the ancestor
of probability Theory what's that other
rule then the other rule man I feel
almost shy telling it to you
but I have to because you have to know
its name it's called the sum rule of
counting
we're going to think about a different
way of counting previously we're
counting by steps you would take an
experiment and try and split it up into
Step A or B or 12 different sub steps
this other way of crouching is we're
going to say we're going to count by ORS
we're going to say my outcomes can
either come from set a or from set B
so if you can have outcomes
which are either from A or B
and you want to count how many outcomes
there are you could use the sum rule of
counting
if you
where there's no element that's in both
of these sets then it turns out the
total number of outcomes
is just going to be the total outcomes
in a plus the total outcomes of B you
could imagine like Steps leads to
multiplication and or leads to addition
uh that's a very special case where
there's no element that's in both we
call these sets mutually exclusive so
there is no element that is both in set
a and in set B
and I want to give you just the
intuitive idea to realize how obvious a
statement what I made is
so we're going to count my daughter's
toys and we're going to live in a world
where she only has balls or plush
animals but oh my God we could talk
about like capitalism and how many toys
there are for kids it drives me crazy
but I wish we only had these toys but we
have more anyways that's not important
right now what is important right now
imagine my daughter only has balls or
plush animals what I'm saying is you can
think of the number of Toys she has is
either coming from set a or set B
and there's no toy that's in both sets
so you can say
um you know there's two toys in this set
and there's three Toys in this set so
I'm saying the total number of sets you
can total number of toys you can just
get by adding you're like Chris are you
really teaching me this at Stanford in a
college level class yes yes I in fact so
how many toys are there just you know
humor me
you're like yes yes there are five
they're in fact five because there is
two from set a and there's three from
set B because they're mutually exclusive
you can just add them
Good Times
okay but like this isn't the end of the
story because this
um this really relies on a very
important rule this is only if
there's no element in a and b
so they're mutually exclusive all right
let's play with this a little bit here's
a more interesting problem and this
problem is going to make us think a
little bit more deeply it's going to
think about both counting with or and
Counting with steps in the same time
you've got these two tools we're going
to try and bring them together okay
here's my problem for you a six bit
string so that's six zeros and ones so
for example here is a valid six bit
string zero zero one one zero zero it's
six bits everything is a one or zero
we're gonna send them over the networks
but the receiver is only going to
recognize as valid bit strings that
start with a 0 1 or end with a one zero
is this valid or invalid
invalid because it neither starts with a
zero one nor does it end with a one zero
our question is let's just practice our
counting and let's count how many valid
strings there are
and you're like whoa how'd you break
this apart
well we have two rules we have you can
take your problem and try and break
things into sets
or if you have a problem you can try and
break things into steps
two mechanisms for taking a big problem
and breaking into a smaller pieces
there is an or in the question because
valid strings either start with zero one
or they start with one zero and when I
see that or in the question my mind
immediately goes to the step rule of
counting so we can say why don't we
count how my strings start with zero one
and how my strings end with one zero we
can split that up and we can just do one
at a time so with the person next to you
can you count how many valid strings are
there that start with a zero one
talk to the person next to you see if
you can use one of these two rules to
break that down and figure out how many
valid strings start with zero one
okay so just to be clear we were given a
gargantuan problem and our job
you know our strategy is to use these
two things to break it into smaller
pieces we did the first step together
which we're going to split it into
counting how many strings start with
zero one and Counting how many strings
end with uh one zero and then the task I
gave you was can you count how many bit
strings start with zero one anyone have
an idea and really if you could appeal
to either the step rule of counting or
the or rule of counting that'd be very
helpful
yes uh at 16 because you know that your
first two numbers have to be zero one
yeah and then you have four more steps
that you need to take yes and so you
take your first step it's either one or
zero so that's two the two choices for
your first step the two choices for your
second step and so on until you have
four steps okay and
you have two choices for the next bit
two choices for this one two choices for
this one two choices for this one that's
fantastic you guys know I like to make
things like
physical it makes things more
interesting for understanding so I've
got here Coke Zeros and Coke ones and
you're like
you should okay okay let's let me just
say something that's on my mind this is
not a Coke series it's a Diet Coke
because I went to the bookstore I was
like do you have Coke series like no we
have Diet codes I'm like no I need a
Coke Zero for my demo and they're like
not at all understand they're like it's
the same number of calories basically
but anyways this is my zero this is my
one step one
start your string has to be zero one
there's only one choice for those first
two
but then you get four more choices you
could either put a zero or one for your
next string
this step has two options then you have
one more choice for the next bit two
choices oh sorry a zero or one
two choices you have to choose one of
them and then we've got one two three
four we've got two more steps left you
know choose one of these two
and then for your very final choice you
have two more choices left so if there
is
one times two times two times two times
two
to the squared to the third to the
fourth sixteen thank you very much
that's exactly right
so
there's two to the fourth strings that
start with zero one if you guys want to
see them all like maybe you don't
believe me there they are there are all
the strings that start to zero one and
like this is what it looks like to
enumerate all of those in fact anytime
you find counting hard use your ability
to write awesome programs and you could
enumerate every single possibility and
really convince yourself so you counted
right
how many strings end with one zero
it's the same thing just backwards there
still are going to be the same number of
steps okay this is
one no it has to end in
one zero so this is my Coke Zero
obviously
this is my Coke one so step one is to
put them at the end of the string and
then there's four places that can either
be or zero or a one and there's two
choices for each of those four steps so
two choices for this one two choice for
this one two choice for this one two
choices for this one so you can think
about it as step one
fix these last two
to be one zero
and then you have four steps left to
construct your string you have two
choices for this step two choices for
this step two choices for this step two
choices for this step very importantly
when you choose our one or zero here it
doesn't change whether or not you can
choose a one or zero here right
if you chose a one this can still be a
one we've chose a zero this can still be
a zero so a number of choices in one
step doesn't affect the number of
choices in another step okay
hey we use both of the rules in one
problem we use the step rule of counting
to figure out how many strings end in
zero one and we use a step row of count
to figure out how many strings and then
one zero now we've got an or of two sets
we have set a and set B and our results
can come from either of them
so we can just add them and you're like
16 plus 16 I'm done and you like take
your answer and you go to your pset app
your fun little piece of app what a good
time
and you go over what's 16 plus 16 real
fast
and you put in your 32 and you hit check
answer and it's checking answer and I
hope I have internet enough to get to my
server oh it's a little optimistic it's
like keep trying you're like you jerk
just tell me I'm right what
did Chris lie I don't lie I try not to
lie but like did he lie something's
wrong somebody knows
they're not
yeah there's three PS4s you gotta get
rid of that
okay the schedule of counting is very
useful as long as step a doesn't change
how many elements are in Step B we can
use it the or rule of counting has this
very hard constraint you can't have
elements that in both sets this is what
that looks like
there is this element here
and that exact same bit string is right
over there we've counted it twice it's
not two different unique strings it's
just one string but we've counted it
twice
so if this was a midterm and you guys
were like I want to get my my partial
credit I want to get the right answer
how would you just hack this together
really quickly
yeah you just like uh subtract four
because I double counted them and you
get uh
28 and you're like uh 28.
so that felt hacky we're just like okay
uh we want to subtract off four but it
turns out subtracting off four is in
fact a very elegant thing to do
if you want to count by ORS in the case
where this condition doesn't hold there
is a very simple fix
you just need to count how many elements
are in this overlap how many elements
are in both if you can count how many
elements are in both you just subtract
off that number so it leads to this more
general rule of counting with or which
is if you want to drop this box then the
total number of outcomes is going to be
the size of elements in set a
plus the size of elements in set B but
then you have to subtract off all of
your double counting and you have to say
let's subtract off all the elements that
are in both sets
can people on that side see this I know
it gets a little bit close to the screen
okay and that leads to the outcome that
is correct and also just the final rule
to learn today it has a fancy name it's
called inclusion exclusion and it is one
of the fundamental ideas of counting in
fact it's very close to one of the
axioms upon which all of probability
theory is based
but it's a pretty simple easy to
understand idea we can count either by
or or by steps and when you count by or
you've got this very general rule if
your outcomes are either coming from set
a or set B you can just use this formula
and this is the summary core counting
really comes down to Counting with steps
or counting with or counting with steps
we can just use multiplication as long
as this constraint holds that step a
doesn't affect step B and when you're
counting with or so outcomes either come
from A or B you can use this formula and
now you've got two great formulas and
this counting with or if you subtract
off the overlap has no limits you can
use it any case you're counting with or
okay
have a challenge for you guys this is my
my little brain teaser to end the day
so Boba we all love it
uh
imagine the letters b-o-b-a that's funny
this image is huge but the letters are
tiny my question for you is how many
unique orderings are there of the
letters b o b a and we can start writing
them out you know
there's one unique ordering
you could do b b o a they don't have to
be valid words I just want to know how
many unique ways could you order all the
letters in boba
and this is our final challenge for
today and you could think if if you can
figure out how many unique ways there
are of doing Boba and you want to bump
it up you can say how many unique ways
are there doing Mississippi and I'm
going to give you guys some time to talk
about that this isn't the answer is it
maybe it is the answer I'm gonna give
everyone a chance to think about it so
think about it how could you figure out
how many unique orderings are there of
the word Boba uh and we're going to be
taking our counting up to the next level
if you want an easier one to start with
if you're finding this hard thinking
about how many unique orderings are
there of something where all the letters
are unique and that would be a easier
problem to solve on your way to the
answer talk to talk about this with the
person next to you let's see where we
can get to
okay
you guys are awesome
I'm so looking forward to the rest of
this quarter this is going to be such a
good ride okay I don't want to talk
about the answer to this harder problem
I want to talk about the answer to this
easier problem where all the letters are
unique and I want to think about
orderings for these number of unique
letters
so
how can we think about the number of
unique ways of ordering A B C or D I'm
going to give you a four-step process
step one choose letter one how many
choices are there
four and let's say you chose a and
there's four choices here
how about first step two my claim is
that your step two is you're going to
choose the second letter
but are there four choices anymore
uh oh is that breaking a rule
the step rule says that
after you make your first choice it can
affect how many choices there are in the
second one
does your choice in the first step
change how many choices you have in the
second one
oh It's Tricky well if you choose a
there's three things left if you choose
B there's three things left if you
choose C there's three things left if
you choose D there's three things left
it turns out no matter what you choose
for the first letter there's still three
things left
so that allows us to use a step rule of
counting so you know there's three
things left and let's say we choose C
know what no matter what you chose for
the first two letters they're still
going to be just two letters left so
your third step is to choose that next
letter and there's two choices so that
could be B and then finally your last
one will be determined because you've
chosen three of the letters that last
one there's not really a choice there's
only one option left no matter what you
chose
your first step changes the options for
your second step
but your first step doesn't change how
many options there are
and it's the second thing that needs to
be true to use a step rule of counting
and since that second thing is true then
the total number of ways of organizing a
b c d is four times three times two
times one
that is easier than thinking about the
orderings of this why is it easier than
think about the orderings of this word
the silly bees oh my God make our lives
so much they're our new beards so I'm
not going to tell you the answer to this
I'm going to leave this as a little bit
of a tease for you guys to try and think
about on your own can you figure out how
many orderings are there if you do
figure it out what you can do
is you can go to the website go find
lecture one use these optional problems
where I just kind of like write up the
things we talked about and you can go
try and if you get your right answer you
can put it in here and you can see if
you got the answer right have a
wonderful rest the first day of the
quarter come back on Wednesday we'll
continue this wonderful journey of cs109
foreign